sus documentos están listos cientos de
aspirantes a refugiados afganos
aglutinaron el domingo en las calles de
kabul a pesar de tener los papeles en
regla a estas familias están atrapadas
desde hace más de una semana nos dicen
que vayamos al aeropuerto allí nos dicen
que vayamos al hotel no sé qué hacer
hay miles de afganos en riesgo que si
ven en el país y que se exponía y van a
ser reubicados pero las evacuaciones
están llegando a su fin los vuelos
franceses que salían de Afganistán
pusieron fin a sus operaciones el
viernes el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron quiere que se establezca una zona
segura cerca del aeropuerto de kabul un
lugar donde los afganos que huyen del
país puedan ser procesados y evacuados a
países cercanos como Qatar
Francia y sus socios están trabajando
para hacer todo lo posible para
garantizar la seguridad de las
operaciones humanitarias
pero algunos expertos advierten que
podría ser una medida arriesgada
podría desencadenar más ataques sus
ideas de Lady K la zona se convertiría
en un objetivo adicional
las fuerzas de paz de Naciones Unidas no
están suficientemente equipadas para
hacer frente a este tipo de amenazas una
vez más la situación vuelve a posicionar
al grupo talibán como una fuerza con la
que hay que negociar
Francia sacó a casi 3000 afganos y están
conversaciones con los talibanes sobre
otras posibles evacuaciones